right so I just want to address certain
comments like this because it's simply
not true and I cannot allow a narrative
to be created that isn't true Okay so
I was not treated badly the whole
episode nor was I treated in any
disrespectful manner throughout all the
episodes that we recorded uh Brother Ali
dawa was the most respectful person
um there were boundaries at no point did
I feel like I wasn't being heard or
wasn't allowed to speak
now if you watch his previous
um episodes you understand that the
bitter buzzers when you hit the bitter
buzzer you have a minute to speak
without any Interruption hence why he
was timing it he kept saying you know
20 seconds uh 30 seconds because no one
was allowed to interrupt me for a whole
minute while I pressed the bitter buzzer
that was the whole concept of why I hit
the buzzer
now I have been seeing a few other
comments about some of the other cast
members on the panel for example
Shaquille
um Shaquille was not in agreeance with
brother Matty and I think as you can see
in the episode we were giggling because
we just couldn't take what brother mehdi
was saying seriously in all honesty you
know we could see through the ACT hence
why well in another episode I won't
spoil it but you'll see in another
episode
um me clearly trolling him about helping
his wives
I think this conversation was very
necessary and needed to be had and
you know I keep seeing a lot of hate as
to why you know this person was allowed
a you know a a platform now
you have people like Piers Morgan who do
documentaries sitting face to face with
murderers who actually committed real
life crimes but it's necessary to
understand their mindset and it's
necessary to have conversations with
those kinds of people and I'm not saying
Matty committed murder or anything like
that however he has a mindset that is
problematic to the Umar and we needed to
address it it's as simple as that so
yeah in terms of this comment it's far
far from the truth